hey guys i'm ryan right hi i'm lauren
god that's right
new girl on the channel lauren god
apparently he's been talking about me
yeah she's Chinese yes I am the best
kind of Asian okay unless I'm next to a
Japanese girl then that's the best kind
of Asian I'm hurt I'm sorry Lauren
I have to be honest sometimes what's
[ __ ] up about the situation is she
actually came over to my place drove
like in power came to my bachelor pad I
was ready to just you know be on my
a-game right had everything set up BAM
we filmed some trailer reactions every
three we did three and it was it was
bomb diggity and it was great footage
and then what happened the mic was not
on so we didn't hear any of it you'll
see this is new we are in Laurens home
my place and I've been kind of tired
today I got suspended from work for
sleeping on the job so it's a day off
today I showed up here and I was like oh
she didn't realize Lauren was a was a
queen I am Chinese royalty this home is
even the bathroom is impressive except
for the fan in the bathroom fix that the
fan bathroom sounds like there are
slaves pushing something to make the
window see but the thing is that it's so
loud in there so you can do whatever you
want and nobody can hear you yeah you're
totally finished [ __ ] jerk-off whatever
you want to do you're gonna have a good
time
I'm very classy with the ladies yeah
we're both wearing some pants by the way
yeah we're both wearing sweatpants
you know sweatpants can't think of a sex
joke sorry Lauren you can't think of a
sex joke I'm trying so disappointed I
try gosh when Asian women get on your
ass you just got to put them back into
place
no because Asian women know everything
yeah they all know [ __ ] are always right
I actually do know comfort so it's
pretty cool that she knows Conor that's
how we met on a martial arts action
short film that my brother's doing
remember the day she came outside I was
loved I am [ __ ] we got a cute girl on
board hell yeah oh she's the other girls
weren't cute that was really made that
videos coming out man
you have created enemies and we're gonna
watch the trailer for 22 Jump Street the
red band trailer
everyone's been pretty much asking that
I checked the
trailer out I love the first 21 Jump
Street I love Channing Tatum Addington
you know Channing Tatum was like a [ __ ]
before chick 21 Jump Street every uh
every one bag on the guy but then when
he did 21 Jump Street well is even
before step up I love that bunch of
other crappy movies he was in that
stripper one yeah that was after 21
Junction was it yeah every good movie is
after 21 Jump Street he wasn't that
movie with Rachel make up the The Vow
yeah and I wasn't very good I love
change him and I love Rachel McAdams and
I love chick flicks but that I was
disappointed you know I love chick
flicks to Lord okay what's up in common
I don't believe that you have chokes you
can't see the notebook because everybody
says the note okay fine I'll come up
with a better one than the wedding
singer no no not matte 50 first dates
you don't like that the wedding singers
better that ending we know you see like
yeah he shows the video ever yes oh so
yeah and join the hills back you and
Jonah hell is killing it out there that
movie was Leonardo DiCaprio's I haven't
seen yet wolf of Wall Street
he's like however it isn't she horrible
anything she says I'm like don't know
what you're saying you just look so cute
I was making complete sense okay so
pizza watch this trailer 22 Jump Street
a relationship is something that
requires constant work he's not even
trying it seriously he's clinging he's
terrified of being by himself getting
all these strong feelings why don't you
hold hands yeah literally reaching out
for you hold my head lock it though if
you don't interlock it might as well
just be friends not partners how you
[ __ ] like Jump Street now hey I got a
big ass raise the babysit you two
[ __ ] again over
[ __ ] boys look like you about P
you don't have C state well but why
every time you speak I'm gonna [ __ ] up
oh my god go to college
yeah actually exciting there is now your
family drink alcohol are you two [ __ ]
around a school again it's to say okay
do the same thing it's not exactly the
same case cuz one of us got laid last
night
put the talking missionary we're talking
missionary when I'm on top of chicken so
either someone's bringing a [ __ ] ton of
that stuff down to Puerto Mexico for
spring break
that's your leave [ __ ] that's
you you gotta take you thinning to the
next level guys you guys do that oh
where you put it feels right oh [ __ ] the
guys always a bad guy yeah
I do write try to get me [ __ ] I kiss
you what a comfortable fistfight I've
ever been this have the best joke for
last that
oh man the cameras already about to die
this really does suck for my life know
how it's really good I know yeah it
looks better
hilarious it looks better than like the
first one in a lot of ways the first
time I saw the trailer for it the other
trailer look like it was just a rehash
this one's like hey no they're actually
taking it a different place I like that
a lot clever comedy writers yes Asian
noises stereotype so clever comedy
writer who is not an Asian you know it
wasn't like hey that is not what you did
we'll see when this video comes out real
fast real fast I gotta do is real shout
out a time Laura knows it man
look I go an order of shout outs okay so
people think sometimes I forget about
them but that's not true my love's
Anthony Smith give great compliments
thank you thank you for all the great
compliments you give you touch my heart
you said a [ __ ] you drop bears United
you asked me for a shout-out bears
united shut up so hello to you you know
what I think of drop bears I think of
like bernstein bears okay
I wasn't thinking you're gonna say that
but alright what do you think it's gonna
be a sex show because I have plenty of
those up in this noggin I don't know you
couldn't think of one earlier so how
dare you drop bears United chakras
United yeah you can okay yeah oh come
with a section for us you'll get another
yeah maybe you'll get another shout out
the crappy 2012 crepe hey 20-day the
crepe eehhh there's only one P that
groupie it's like therapy with a scene
tell us how to pronounce your [ __ ]
name you called dibs dance tips well
we're gonna keep talking for you while
this battery dies out until he gets to
the 10th we're gonna see how people
respond to you and if you like Lauren
comment below and tell us if you around
I won't be back
you guys really got to give a good
petition here come on she's keep man I
need an excuse to keep seeming more fun
facts about Lauren oh gosh she's
flexible
I've seen her stretch and that's when I
went up to her and I'm like hey Brian
alright that you do and it was a smooth
and she was swept off her feet but now
she has a boyfriend
every girl tells me err clutch
physically what's really attractive
about Wow hope he watches this one day
then maybe I'll have a chance I had to
keep him on yeah